he is a multi-talented singer music
producer las vegas headliner just to
name a few things donnie osmond is in
studio with us today and he has a lot
going on but he's taken some time to
spend with us and you at home today his
residency at harris is in full effect
there you can see him take the stage
while he sings his biggest hits and when
he's not busy headlining his spectacular
show he's busy making his fans dreams
come true take a look
[Music]
it's a big
[Applause]
that was so fun
you are the the kindest man donny ottman
is here everyone yeah i surprised
jennifer the other day and don cheadle
the actor don cheadle was sitting right
next to us after it was all over he gets
up to leave because she says
that was cool and i said don you're next
she had two dogs donnie and daughter at
the same time nice to see you again it's
so good to have you back and you're
headlining again but this time this is
donnie in big lights well it's it's uh
pretty much everything i've done in show
business for the last last six decades
in a 90-minute show i don't know how we
did it but we did it i am so impressed
with this new showroom you you guys went
through a lot to get it done right yes
we tore out the sound when the lighting
everything is brand new the show is
brand new in fact it was talked to
somebody yesterday you saw the show he
said donnie it's not a show it's a
broadway production yes it's that huge
now you have a long history of
being in vegas since you were a little
oh i started here when i was seven what
what's your earliest memory of las vegas
and uh i was opening for shirley bassey
and mickey rooney uh came on once in a
while
and uh
and i've seen this city change so much
and right now it's the best it's ever
been because there's so many wonderful
things here in las vegas i love this
city we finally bought a house finally
after living in the hotel for 14 years i
finally said i gotta be civil we bought
a home and my wife debbie absolutely
loves it
so now i am a resident of
las vegas part of this community but you
have been for a while just not formally
exactly so the new show
i heard a rumor about it is it true that
you actually rap in it oh i do you rap i
came up with this idea i called raj
kapoor who was my creative director he
said uh
i would pay money to watch donny osmond
rap so we started writing this thing it
starts it all began back in utah i was
four years old started singing with my
brothers and the sound was like gold so
my folks took a leap and said what the
hey we got to get these monsters out to
california and it goes faster
10 minutes long
and it's practically everything and
everything i say is on the huge screens
behind me and it is so much fun has
become a fan favorite as i start to
introduce and i hear people like here it
comes here he comes here he comes
it's so much fun
you have so much talent you can rap
and then you have a segment of your show
too where people just shout their
requests at you
this one took me about a year to figure
out okay because i just released my 65th
album so which album do you highlight in
a 90 minute show so i said let's put
every album i've ever done in the show
so for about 15 minutes it's complete
improv
and all the albums are on the screen
anybody can pick any song from any album
i've ever recorded in my entire life and
we do it just like that so if i threw
out just a couple of songs would you be
able to give me a little piece now
you're going to test me
okay all right uh let's put my money
where my mouth is right you know i love
joseph and the amazing technicolor
dreamcoat okay close every door close
every door to me hide all the world from
me bar all the windows and shut out the
light in fact i do that song and instead
of bringing uh jail bars in like i did
as joseph we create these
these bars out of beams of light oh my
god and as it crescendos and it changes
the beams of light go into a diagonal
but into a diagonal the stage is full of
fog it is
so i mean it gives me chills to think
about it
to defeat
the huns in fact i got permission from
disney to use the film and it's like an
eight-minute huge production number we
do the same stick fight dancing as
captain chang behind me on the screen
and we turn the whole theater into a
mulan experience oh my gosh this i i
can't wait to see the show i'll give you
one more okay and it's probably the one
you hear most okay
and they called it puppy love
that's my fourth song and i don't make
fun of it i just sing it legitimately
it's a beautiful arrangement and we turn
the whole theater in you see these huge
posters of me when i was in this
horrible 70s outfit i was in
on the side screens and i just sing it
legitimately and i love every bit of it
i heard a fan actually came up to you
and said you got to stop making fun of
that song that's what changed me what
happened she said you may have had a hit
with that song but puppy love was a big
part of my childhood memories and you
have no right to mess with my memories
stop me in my tracks and from that
moment on i sing it with respect because
you know what people it does belong to a
lot of other people not just me
you are truly uh one of those
celebrities that it's like when you meet
them it's almost too good to be true
like how can you be
you can tell you love your fans so much
i do
you truly are a blessing to be in this
city to have you as our headliner we're
so lucky well mercedes when you get
right down to it how many people have
the fortunate uh privilege of performing
for 60 years and have their own
show headline show on the strip i'm very
fortunate and i'm grateful for every bit
of it and you uh don't age also i just
want to say that what what is going on
not bad for 104 huh
thank you donny osmond everybody you can
see donnie osmond at harris las vegas he
has show scheduled through november get
your tickets online i know i'm getting
mine ticketmaster.com donnie we will be
right back